welcome to the top 10 news stories of
the month we comb through all the
headlines so you can stay up to date on
the games you love hit that subscribe
button and we'll bring the hottest
stories right to you March brought us
new characters a few controversies and a
brand new nintendo console these are the
top 10 news stories number 10 / watches
next hero after an arg that seemed to
last half a year with sombra / watches
latest hero was revealed in a mercifully
shorter time frame orissa is a defense
robot who can draw on her opponents with
a gravity burst buff her teammates and
even temporarily reduced damage to
herself even though big robots tend to
be a bit clumsy
arisa is a much more reliable droid and
you can get your hands on her right now
head over to gamespot for our hero guide
if you need a few tips number nine an
assassin's creed TV show so you've got
games that come out almost every year
and a mediocre movie what do you do next
announce a TV series of course I
shouldn't be so negative though Ubisoft
did take a year off from Assassin's
Creed games and the plan is to quote
take our time to get sure we deliver
something we can be proud of Ubisoft CEO
Eve Gilmore also said that the company
has been in talks with Netflix so at
least they seem to be taking a real stab
at it at whatever let's move on number
eight game freak's job listing remember
all those rumors about a Nintendo switch
game called pokémon's stars well Sun and
Moon developer Game Freak had a job
listing for quote an RPG game that is
popular on a global scale now I'm no
detective but the only game that seems
to fit that bill is Pokemon and the job
listing says the project is meant for
consoles so this pokemon game could
really switch things up and you guys are
mean today number seven Starcraft gets
remastered okay maybe this will get the
studio audience on my side you guys
remember starcraft right well it's
getting remastered that's better
Starcraft remastered has all the content
from the first game plus the brood war
expansion 4k support matchmaking and
cloud save options it's the starcraft
you remember for the modern era and it's
releasing this summer number 6 the red
dead GTA 5 mod speaking of pc games
Grand Theft Auto seems to get a new bod
every day but one team is taking things
further by bringing the entirety of red
dead redemption into GTA 5 they want to
eventually get all of John marstons
missions and abilities in there too but
that's a long term goal for now we'll
just have to enjoy watching Michael fly
over new Austin while
I out of his mind number five Bolivia
mad at ghost recon red dead took us down
to Mexico and Ghost Recon wildlands took
us down to Bolivia but the Bolivian
government isn't too happy with a game
all about ridding their country of a
massive drug cartel interior minister
Carlos Romero wants to negotiate some
changes with Ubisoft and he's even
lightly threatened some legal action
wildlands is clearly a work of fiction
but if Bolivian officials want to take
this thing to court that's their
prerogative so much for ghosts going
undetected we are ghosts number four out
last two is Australian band speaking of
video games and legal matters did you
know outlast to was briefly banned in
australia the ratings board didn't care
for its use of violence gore drugs sex
and other mature content and it didn't
think anyone else should be experiencing
it developer red barrels resubmitted in
hopes of an r18 plus rating and managed
to pull it off but the thing is none of
the content was altered in the now legal
version of the game so you'll be able to
experience all the violent gory sexy
drug-filled terror when out last two
launches on April 26th in Australia or
one day earlier in the US number 3 Xbox
game pass if you're looking to get your
hands on as many games as possible then
let me introduce you to xbox game pass
microsoft recently revealed the new
service which gets you unlimited access
to a library of games for ten bucks a
month the games rotate every month but
you can buy anything you'd like to keep
at a discount an Xbox game pass doesn't
affect games with gold at all so if you
consider yourself an xbox fan you've got
tons of stuff to play for cheap and for
free number two Nintendo's fastest
selling console if you're more of a
Nintendo person then you'll be happy to
know the switch is doing well like
record-breaking ly well it's old faster
than any other Nintendo console in the
Americas Europe and Australia
yes that does mean it's old faster than
even the we maybe it's time for Grandma
to trade we bowling for links latest
adventure especially since breath of the
wild is also Nintendo's best-selling
standalone launch game ever I never won
the Spelling Bee as a kid but even I
know that that spells success number one
destiny to revealed after heaping
helping of rumors and a short teaser
trailer we finally got a cinematic look
at destiny to with a debut trailer
featuring commander zavala and Kade they
promised a ton of loot as you'd expect
and the whole thing wraps up with a sep
tember 8th release date and promises
abeyta it won't be long before we meet
more Wizards from the moon on ps4 xbox
one and at last PC and those are the
biggest news stories we're still talking
about you gotta love new games and
people getting mad about the new games
but if you want to get glaad instead
make sure you like and subscribe to
gamespot for all the biggest news
reviews and awesome original shows keep
on gaming guys
[Music]